NARRATOR: Although completely
invisible to the naked eye,
a virtual universe of
electromagnetic waves
permeates our entire world.
And this vast
network of impulses
carries within it
information and data
that we have come to depend
on in our digital age.
[music playing]
It is the backbone of
what is otherwise referred
to as the cloud,
which remotely stores
billions of gigabytes of data.
When we think about the cloud
what we're really talking about
is data transfer,
information transfer.
You're sending bits of
information through the air,
wirelessly, up to satellites
down to servers, back again,
into your computer,
into your phone.
And there's close
to 7 billion people
using cloud computing now.
So you can imagine that pretty
much anywhere on the planet
that has internet
access, you're going
to find these hidden, sort
of, secret patterns and codes
that are floating around us.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: According
to historians,
the concept of an
Intergalactic Computer Network
was first proposed by scientist,
J.C.R Licklider, in the 1960s.
However, ancient
astronaut theorists
suggest that the idea may
actually trace all the way back
to our ancient past.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: Korva
island, Raichur, India.
Religious pilgrims
seeking enlightened wisdom
travel here to a
temple dedicated
to the celestial sage, Narada.
According to the
Hindu scriptures,
Narada had the
supernatural ability
to gain access to
a hidden domain
that most humans are
completely unaware of,
the realm of cosmic knowledge.
[music playing]
Tales about Narada appear
in the Mahabharata, in
the Ramayana, in the Puranas.
Tradition has it that Narada
transcendent consciousness
to gather his stories and give
teachings of great wisdom.
DEEPAK SHIMKHADA: Narada
is called Narada Rishi.
Rishis are like sages
in Western concept.
So they have gained
this ability to be
able to tap into the
knowledge, access
that knowledge directly
from the cosmos.
[music playing]
Narada is interesting
specifically that he clearly
had access to an essential
knowledge that is at the fabric
of the divine cosmic order.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: This idea of an
otherworldly repository
of cosmic information is
most commonly referred
to today as the Akashic record.
The term was coined in 1883
by author Alfred Percy Sinnett
in his book,
"Esoteric Buddhism."
In it, he describes how
according to Eastern
philosophy, universal
records physically
exist in the ever
pervasive realm known
as the Akasa, which
can be accessed
by enlightened individuals.
[music playing]
DEEPAK SHIMKHADA: Akashic
is a Sanskrit word.
It means the sky.
So Akashic records can be
considered as cosmic knowledge.
So it is belonging
to the cosmos.
Everything is
written in the sky.
It's not belonging
to human beings.
You simply cannot go and
bring it in a tangible form.
It's something that can be
accessed through your mind,
through your brain
power, through
your spiritual wavelength.
[music playing]
The Akashic feel it's the
immeasurable potential of all
that was, is, and will ever be.